Tâm đó thì giữ lật nếu quy định phân quyền nhận vụ thông báo các ngày nghĩ lễ tất cả nằm gió bộ trở mụ nơi vụ thực hiện.
Đồng thời bộ xung đời hạ tất cả những vụ thông báo ngày nghĩ của nằm tiếp theo.
Chên các dở quất định của tụ tướng gió bộ nơi vụ thông yêu.
Trước ngày bà mấy tần chiến, nằm trước lên cây, như vậy thì giữ thảo đã phân quyền nhận vụ thông báo cuộc thế ngày nghĩ lễ tất,
hẳng nằm gió bộ trở mụ nơi vụ thực hiện.
Đồng thời bộ xung thời hạ tất cả những vụ thông báo ngày nghĩ của nằm tiếp theo.
Chên cơ sở quất định của thủ tướng chính phủ, gió bộ nơi vụ thông yêu vào trước ngày bà mấy tần chiến, nằm trước lên cây.
Lẽ sức này, nằm tạo điều kiện cho cán mộ công trước vình trước, vừa rất vừa rất vừa rất giành giập trở bị các chương trình, kế hoạch phủ hợp,
chẳng điều thục báo sát nhận nghĩ về khó khám cho vừa rất vừa rất vừa, trong vừa gị lễ tất nhiều hệ này.
Mọi giá thì giữ lật còn bộ xung thêm một ngay lễ là ngày văn hóa viet nào.
Mọi người thử tháng 12, nằm thề chế hoạch nghĩ của tắm mời của bộ trình chiến.
Bởi phát triển bản hó viet nằm, quý đệ 12, nằm là ngày văn hó viet nằm.
Và là ngày gị, người laud động được hưởng vừa rất.
Nhiều một trong 12, bộ lần đầu động, anh hiểu không chắc bởi chiến, quý đệ, người laud động được nghĩ là hưởng vừa,
nguyên lương trong 12, nổi lễ tất.
Mộm tất dưỡng lịch tất miến đáng, gió tổ hưởng vừa, ngày chiến tắng bám bây tần tư.
Cúc tế lo đậu một một tâm nắm, có khảy mùng hát tình chiến và một ngày đến cây, cũng ngày có khảy nữ,
mà lo đậu nước ngoài mà có tích.